we've stumbled onto this talk about
america and we were talking about
hollywood
so i'm going to make this segment happen
because i'm so excited for this
the first thing i want to say is this if
if i could offer you up
all of you guys listening a tv show
where a guy takes an american flag
and brutally beats antifa and
you know he rejects a bunch of woke
ideas he's repeatedly told
by you know people about how uh you know
you know you shouldn't you shouldn't
wave that flag it's the white man's flag
and that you gotta understand and so you
have this this black man who says nah i
like the flag and he picks it up
and then there are these people who are
like we should have open borders and
we're gonna we're gonna smash the flag
and then he just beats him with it
would that be a show conservatives would
want to watch it sounds great
where do i sign up where do i get it
it's the falcon and the winter soldier
so first let me show this story from we
got this covered
that we talked about i think a couple
weeks ago new rumor says over 80
of falcon and winter soldier viewers
turned off episode two at the same point
now i'm talking about this you know
we're talking about hollywood wokeness
the commercialization of this anger
and i i i got to talk about the show and
i think pride fits in because i'm
wondering why it is i see a lot of
people saying this show is woke don't
watch it it's awful it's racist
people don't want to watch it and i
wonder if there's an element of pride in
assuming hollywood does this so not
maybe not giving it a chance
yeah maybe being being a little more
open-minded so
we have this this this segment from uh
marvel.com or this this article
cast and creative creatives behind the
falcon winter soldier discuss patronism
supremacy captain america's mantle and
you have this this quote from anthony
mackey
who plays excuse me he plays
the falcon he says for sam it's a
constant battle of how do you fight for
a country that's never fought for you
remarks anthony mackie explaining in
many ways the one thing that held up the
moniker of that shield was the idea of
who steve rogers was which is captain
america
that comment to me was really
interesting because it does i think in
many ways show that marvel
they're woke and they don't get it for
anthony mackie to say that a country
never fought for you i mean i think one
of the bloodiest battles in the history
of the world was the civil war right
quite literally to end slavery among
other you know
peripheral factors but that was a key
component but here's what i got to say
about this show
and what hollywood is doing and what we
need to be careful of i'm seeing a lot
of people tell me i'm wrong because i
said the show's not woke
i'm like it's not woke give it a chance
it's actually my it's fairly centrist
it addresses issues of race but quite
literally
i'm going to spoil the show for those
who haven't seen the finale because the
felony finale came out and i was
so excited watching a dude reject
wokeness
pick up the american flag and and beat
antifa with it i mean that like i don't
literally like antifa getting beaten but
the bad guys are called flag smashers
yeah they want open borders
they they're terrorists who kill people
they think might makes right and because
they have
super strength they're allowed to kill
whoever they want she literally says
to that there's a soldier with ptsd you
watch his best friend who's a black man
get killed
and she says his life doesn't matter and
i was like that's an amazing indictment
of
these fake woke antifa who would use
someone for political points if they
could get ahead and then literally tell
you to your face they don't matter
anthony mackie plays a black man who
questions whether or not he should wear
the american flag
ultimately decides to do it and they
even show a scene
where there is there's another black man
who says no self-respecting black men
would wear that shield
and anthony mackie says i know those
people who'll be mad at me for wearing
this
but you know he wants to fight for this
country and he'll be damned if someone
tells him he can't do it
and then he he's literally wearing the
american flag
chasing down open borders extremists i'm
like i'm sorry i mean
there's definitely a message about
racism being bad but it sounds like a
more
classically liberal or even a
conservative statement about why racism
is bad well it's obviously conservative
in the sense that
america is good and the flag smashers
are bad i mean just in the most basic
sense that is a conservative
message right you're going to make me i
was at one and a half
marvel products is what i had you're
going to make me go to two and a half
now
i certainly think there's elements that
people could call woke but i wonder if
what a lot of people i did say i tweeted
it was getting too woke
and it was after this point where a car
pulls up as a squad car pulls up and you
got you know anthony mackey
and you got falcon and bucky barnes a
white guy a black guy and it was this
very
stereotypically like racist moment where
the cops were like sir are you all right
to the white dude
a lot of people got mad about that yeah
but i'm like
uh i'm gonna watch it because i don't
want to fall into this trap where i'm
like that's what i woke i won't watch it
yeah
and then i was amazingly surprised there
was a point where apparently
you know sam sam wilson the falcon black
man is
is you know bucky barnes apologizes
saying i didn't realize what it meant
for a black man to wear
you know that shield and be captain
america but he's like
i don't he doesn't want to do that he
has a little kid tell him
he's walking on the street little kid
goes it's black falcon he goes nah i'm
just a falcon
and the kid goes no my dad says you're
black falcon he goes i'm just the falcon
and i'm like you are just the falcon
yeah like your racism
is is not relevant to you being a
superhero who's awesome yeah and when he
decided to defy
people in this black community who said
you think you can come in here because
you have that white man's shield
and he's like but i like that guy he was
cool is my friend he's like steve rogers
didn't do this to you
and then he decides to wear the american
flag representing the country
even aft for every reason he felt like
he he was wrong by this country or
didn't fight for him
for every you know for everyone telling
him that america was bad and doesn't
represent him and hates him
he still believed in this country and
i'm like
it's like hardcore nationalists yeah
it's like it's like almost trumpian in a
way i'm actually i'm wondering if it's
chinese propaganda in that they have now
incited antiqua to go riot and burn
things down for a couple years now
they're gonna start making art about why
we should fight them
yeah it's the it's the 4d chess of the
chinese communists yeah
i i did think about this and i wonder to
what extent there's a conspiracy in
media
now that the election's over they need
to stop antifa
and start putting out messages about
loving the country and
getting things back on track because you
know we were promised the riots would
stop once joe biden came in and they
ain't stopping they're getting worse
yeah well that is the problem when you
when you unleash
violence you don't get to control it you
know actually things say this is
when you begin a war you know things
quickly spiral out of
out of control and that that's clearly
what's going on here but i i am
i'm actually glad you told me this about
marvel because conservatives do this a
lot where they
they'll see a little because because
we're so abused because this whole
culture
abuses and abuses just smacks us all the
time
we just the minute we see someone say
okay that's all i'm done i'm done i
can't take it anymore
and there was that movie that came out i
don't even remember the name of it it
was supposed to come out a few years ago
and it was about how these white rich
liberals
you know i don't even know if it was all
white people was it was the hunt right
it was really good it seemed
great i mean the whole thing was these
these rich coastal libs
were hunting down good regular americans
and
you know i thought this is the most
conservative movie ever made i only saw
the trailer
and then there was a backlash from not
from libs it was from conservatives who
said how dare you hunt me down you think
like
do you get the point of the movie yeah
even trump came out
trump that's right even i came out and
my point was i think we're in too
divisive of a time to be making a video
where liberals are kidnapping and
hunting down conservatives
they might think it's a it's like a nice
movie yeah but it's a plan yeah right
so i was like i don't want to see that
thing and then i did
and it was as i would say it's it's
actually
not partisan isn't good there was like
it made fun of everybody yeah and i'll
say this about falcon and winter soldier
maybe it's conservative like you should
watch it and tell me what you think you
know
but i think it's actually fairly
centrist i think it's fairly la it's not
trying to
in many ways it opposes wokeness yeah
but it does address
the the animosity and the feelings of
racism in in an interesting way
so i think there's a lot of people who
who i'll put it this way
to me wokeness represents insulting
denigrating beating someone over the
head yeah telling them they're stupid or
evil or wrong or privileged
whereas actual social justice as a
as i understood it would be like someone
calmly and explaining to you with
respect
how they feel when it comes to racism
wow so when you go woke it's really
you're going out you're getting angry
well but you're but you're
it's almost like if i was if i was going
to insult you and say you're you know
you're stupid this person that person
your identity
that to me is like what we see with
wokeness it's this idea that
white people have some kind of inherent
badness to them or something
that whiteness represents more like it's
the most insane thing so you could take
on social justice i think you shouldn't
be twerking for kids
but if you start going you're an idiot
for twerking for kids then you're
becoming woke
it's it's well there's there's a couple
couple things one i think a lot of
wokeness is
a quest for power not a quest for
compassion certainly
so you're wrong bend your knee or else
i'll take your job away
yeah whereas what i see in the falcon
winter soldier is
you know there's one guy who uh one of
the characters
seems to me to represent wokeness
animosity towards white people
and the american flag and the main
character rejects that and says no i
like this flag i'm going to fight for
this country
well you know it's it's all negat
everything you've just described is
purely negative right
wokeness is this purely negative
campaign and it's that's just the new
term for political correctness there's
all sorts of terms part of what the left
does is just change the terms all the
time so that that's the new one
but it gets back to something that karl
marx said
which is getting back to quoting karl
marx every so often
karl marx in a letter uh in
oh gosh i forget the year he called for
the ruthless
criticism of all that exists and this
was taken up later by
radical marxist theorists and a
practical politician antonio gramsci
in his construction of what you'd call
cultural hegemony western marxism
this is taken up in the frankfurt school
and critical theory
which now we see the derivation of
critical race theory it's dominated the
universities that is the
woke indoctrination comes from critical
theory and
once you get past all the pretentious
jargon in these crazy theater what is
the theory it's very simple the theory
is to criticize
it's the same thing marx called for it's
just because guess what
i i've noticed this about bigots
you know my friend andrew clavin points
this out a lot
bigots are not always wrong about the
other guy
they're just wrong about themselves you
know they're really good at criticizing
everybody else but they don't see their
own flaws everything is susceptible to
criticism so it's a very
very easy sort of new pseudo-academic
discipline
and there's no end to it it's just
rubble is going to be the end of it i i
think
you know one of one of one of the ways
to look at it is uh
i had a conversation with trump a bunch
of trump supporters over dinner when i
was in i think was in california
this was during like the trump campaign
era i think it was uh
maybe just after i got elected and i was
talking about
historical racism and immediately the
reaction was like laughter and like
you know oh yeah yeah and i was like i
was like legit no like i mean it
sincerely i mean it's seriously
not joking and then i explained to them
like redlining and blockbusting yeah
well we actually have
legit racist policies in this country
that have a negative impact on
communities
you know of color into the uh into the
modern era
but institutionally we've actually made
that all illegal however the remnants
still exist
and so the way i see it is when i treat
people with respect
and say just hear me out on this because
i want to understand you
you get respect back that's that i think
is totally fine
i i actually have no problem with seeing
that in a tv show the issue is when
instead of saying like michael let me
explain to you something about my
experience they say
you're a stupid white man nazi
fascist and like when movies are
predicated upon
berating and insulting you yeah that's
get well go bro well you know the the
late philosopher roger scrutin pointed
this out he said civilization
thrives on forgiveness
on confession first and then forgiveness
and when i confess that i've done
something wrong
even if it's confessing historical
wrongs at the national level whatever
i sacrifice my pride and when you
forgive me
you sacrifice your resentment and we we
have both sacrificed something that we
cherish
that really means a lot to us and that's
the only way you can move forward but if
you're not going to get that if you're
going to have a whole
culture permeated by resentment where
you get it ever
you get it in school you get it in
sometimes as a matter of law
and you get it even when you want to
relax and go to the movies and that's
all you get
it's pride right right it's really
interesting because i've had so many
experiences where
i i've always been very confident in
myself
i don't need to justify or validate
myself to others
and so i just you know i don't but
there's a lot of people who are proud
yeah they need others to know how good
they are how big they are
and it gets them in trouble well you
know true humility does away with false
modesty there are some there's some
people who can't take a compliment
that's just another form of pride
right that's just a kind of that's just
the flip side of it but but true
humility you can say yeah okay i did
this right this was all right you know
hey thanks man it's cool
moving on focusing on other things
trying to move forward in 2006 i decided
to use youtube videos as a form of
confession
and i started making videos about my
past and my history and the mistakes and
the lies i've told
and it allowed me to clear my mind i was
able to start thinking
full complete sentences and i had i can
have a silent mind now
you're a braver man than i am when i
want to confess i go into a little black
box with a scrim where i change my voice
and stuff that's very ridiculed so hard
for so many years to this day i will
still i still get comments on those
videos they're all up online and i would
introduce
why'd you do it if you don't mind social
experiment i thought someone could what
would jesus do with this technology yeah
he would conservatively prostrate
himself to the huma to the humanity and
beg them to come together
so i tried that pride go with before the
fall
yes i was like i remember that i gotta
look that up i
i i think about that especially in the
context of news all of these journalists
are so desperate for validation yeah
their pride consumes them they won't
admit when they're wrong they refuse to
be wrong and they'd rather win above all
else
we need humility desperately yeah but we
the problem is because i agree oh if
only we could do that and you could
everyone would just confess and it'd be
cool right
but the the problem is right now with
with cancel culture which is a real
phenomenon
it's it's a it's a very specific
phenomenon it's a leftist phenomenon
when the left says well you know in the
50s conservatives canceled communists
yep we did that was awesome
that's great every society has
boundaries but what's going on right now
is that if you go wave the flag
the american flag or you don't go along
with some woke
fashion to castrate kids or something
then you lose your job that is cancel
culture
and if you uh
in any way admit that you're wrong let's
say you actually legitimately do
something wrong i
on occasion have done that and i i wish
that i could apologize for that
you you can't because the minute that
you apologize
you're dead they will never forgive you
you saw with the guy who hosted the
bachelor
you saw it with all a number of other
journalists sometimes
you're dead there's so you so what do
you have to do you you simply cannot
enact that humility yep it's an
admission of guilt
it's an admission of guilt and you won't
there's no redemption so you gotta yeah
i lost i was in hollywood as an actor
and after i started doing that no one
would cast me they thought i was like
dangerous
that which i was because i would call i
would have called them out and destroyed
that you got to keep the secrets
disgusting secretive community i would
have and
they knew that look look at uh you know
harvey
people do for they do forgive but
if you're if you have a job that you can
lose you'll probably lose it
if you go that route and you try to be
humble um if you work for yourself
you're in a much better position
and youtube ads you know you can kind of
work for yourself there i don't know i'm
getting off on a tangent
well you can you you can build a
business but i find it fascinating that
uh
the the left i think is consumed by
pride
yes i think that's that's a big factor
and i think when you are you can't admit
when you're wrong
yeah and if you can't admit when you're
wrong you can't improve yourself will
you ever notice this about stupid people
is stupid people think that they're
really really smart
and then smart people the first thing
you notice about smart people
is that they're very aware of how stupid
they are and it's not false modesty
they're actually aware of it because
maybe i don't know maybe the smart
person met a smarter person one time
and just kind of put it all into
perspective it is a it is a
fail proof uh rule of thumb the the
loudest voices in the room who are
there there they are they are i will
never admit that they're wrong thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you